As often happens when great men or great women
die, there's this effort to sort of boil down
their entire life to a single sentence at
the beginning of an obituary.
You know, Lincoln gets two sentences: "He
freed the slaves," and "He saved the union."
Reagan gets: "He won the Cold War."
And people are looking to do the same thing
with Justice Scalia, and the problem is, that's
not how he set about to do things.
He, first of all, has a huge legacy in specific
cases, but I think what he was really trying
to do is play the long game, and he wrote
his descents with law students in mind, with
future generations in mind.
He wanted to put handholds on the cliff face
for future scholars, future lawyers, and future
justices to grab hold onto, to restore the
constitution to its proper role in American
life, and that is a multi-generational task.
And that is who he was writing to, that's
who his audience was, and I think that is
his greatest legacy.